foreign
comes from Lauren in New Mexico she says
my husband claims to be a air quotes
Dave Ramsey guy to his credit we are now
debt free with no mortgage but we are
not on the same page financially I do
not know how much money is in our
accounts nor do I know what accounts we
have or how much money he makes he is
self-employed with a few business
ventures I currently do not have a job
as I oversee care for my 85 year old
father and homeschool our special needs
daughter I can figure it out all out by
force but want him to share and include
me voluntarily do I keep waiting for a
calm and peaceful inclusion in our
finances or do I just gather the
information against his will and move on
Lauren that will never come
there will never be a moment he's
driving down the road and thanks to
himself whoa
I'm an arrogant jerk who uses um Wheels
I know something you don't know as a
form of power in my marriage
or you know what I treat my wife like a
seven-year-old daughter
um
that's never gonna happen
it's not gonna happen
you're gonna have to sit down and say
not knowing our financial position not
knowing where the money is what you owe
what businesses you have
scares me to death
I can't breathe when I think about our
money because I don't know where it is I
don't know our I don't know anything
and if you die
I don't know what to do next
and if you live I don't know what to do
next
and I'm watching my 85 year old dad pass
away in front of me I'm homeschooling
her special needs daughter I am already
exhausted both psychologically and
spiritually and like physically
I need you to be on the same page with
me
that's where you start and here's the
scary thing about being vulnerable like
the idea of vulnerability is rolling an
animal rolling over and showing its
belly it can get hurt
you put that on the table and he looks
at you and says I'm not talking to you
about this
which could happen it's a risk
um then you have
bigger issues and my gut tells me you
know you have bigger issues
this is not indicative of a healthy
marriage and usually people are not
unhealthy in one place
usually if you get the flu your whole
body hurts and you throw up and you got
the rockets and you've you're you know
all you feel your head hurts all of you
hurt
my guess is this is just a small piece
of a larger relationship issue that you
need to deal with okay
um George what do you think I I just
don't know what to believe about this
guy like there's he's saying they're
dead free with no mortgage she has no
idea because she's not involved in any
of the finances he's got bit she doesn't
even know what kind of business ventures
he's into and so this all seems like
it's built on a House of Lies and while
she may be in a great place financially
merrily this is a terrible situation and
I I'm gonna go with maybe maybe he tells
you you're out of debt you don't know he
uh tells you that uh
something happens he goes I had no idea
he had four different credit cards in a
different account that I had no and he
racked up all this debt and now he's
disappeared or he's passed away and then
you're left
while grieving with this whole financial
picture to deal with going I don't know
the login to the bank account right and
let's make no mistake you are not a Dave
Ramsey guy if your wife does not have a
sequel I mean an equal if not more
powerful seat at the table it was a
bonus chapter of Total Money Makeover
what Dave said don't talk about money
with your spouse make sure to keep all
accounts separate secret yeah no this is
not part of the plan we don't even know
if her name is on the bank account
that's right or on the mortgage if you
have ever had the opportunity to sit at
a table with Dave and Sharon
you would know that Laura and your
husband is not a Dave Ramsey guy because
Sharon knows everything and please tell
him to stop self-proclaiming that that's
embarrassed it's embarrassing to all of
us yeah he paid off his credit cards
great good job man paid off his mortgage
maybe good
do the next hard thing which is sit down
with your wife and explain where all the
money is how it works and stop using I
know something you don't know as a as a
tool of power it's the weakest form of
leadership is I know something you don't
know it's the worst